[主播] 都能找我这样长相的主播，你说这直播间能有钱到哪去？
[主播] 经常有朋友在直播间听听，说能不能找一个好看的男主播？
[主播] 我们狗也是有需要心情的。
[主播] 我能理解你，但是陈切办不到。
[主播] 我便宜。
[主播] 你和招路一般昂贵。
[主播] 你和青春一般宝贵。
[嘉宾] 你又拍了16单。
[主播] 你和这个水蜜桃一般的。
[嘉宾] 18名了。
[主播] 18名。
[嘉宾] 还送锅啊。
[主播] 干啥18名？
[嘉宾] 带锅榜。
[嘉宾] 18名。
[主播] 崔花加油，你就和崔花要增加。
[主播] 崔花。
[嘉宾] 赶紧。
[主播] 等我。
[主播] 赶紧啊。
[主播] 每次看到这个桃子，我内心就燃起一股油中的喜悦。
[主播] 我昨天给大家分享过罗素那段话，就是说 'Free passions simple but overwhelmingly strong have governed my life: the search for love, the longing for knowledge, and unbearable pity for the suffering of mankind'。
[主播] 说对知识的渴望，对爱情的追求，对人类苦难难以遏制的同情心，三种简单而强烈的激情，苦苦支配着我的一生。
[主播] 你听，对知识的渴望。
[主播] 什么叫知识？我给你讲知识，桃子叫做 peach。
[主播] 它的口感是 juicy。
[主播] 它的口感还有这个 juicy and sweet。
[主播] 导演你直接上上500单，让大家自己去拍吧。
[嘉宾] 好的。
[主播] 大家都自觉一些。
[主播] 把家庭作业都拿出来，我检查一下。
[主播] 你看崔花你买了吗？
[主播] 白听啊。
[主播] 空手走啊，好意思吗？
[主播] OK,这叫做知识。
[主播] 什么叫做对爱情的追求？
[主播] 不要把它狭隘的理解为男女之爱。
[主播] 'It's not love between lovers, it's love between family members, it's love between mothers and sons, it's love between strangers, it's love between friends, okay?'
[主播] 爱可以是任何人之间的爱。
[主播] 当你怀着爱去看别人的时候，你会发现世界都很美好。
[主播] 我今天一大早看我们抖音粉丝群里大家吵架，我很难受。
[主播] 以责人之心，以责己之心，以责人之心责己，以恕己之心恕人。
[主播] 世界就豁然明朗，豁然大明白。
[主播] 为什么要痛苦呢？
[主播] 人生短短几个秋，不醉不罢休，吃个桃就醉了，你不信你试试。
[主播] 拍一下，我这个桃吃了。
[主播] 吃了没啥用，就是开心，就是开心。
[主播] 赶紧拍，赶紧拍。
[主播] 你。
[嘉宾] 我们牛排还有八单啊。
[主播] 还有八单。
[主播] 快， juicy and sweet。
[主播] juicy and sweet,大家赶紧去拍。
[主播] 右下角一号链接，右下角一号链接的牛排。
[主播] 还有右下角几号链接的桃子。
[主播] 赶紧去拍，赶紧去拍。
[主播] 二号链接的桃子。
[主播] 你这都不买是吧？
[主播] 你不买是吧？
[主播] 你不买我就打自己，让你心疼。
[嘉宾] 崔花心疼。
[主播] 崔花心疼，那我打。
[主播] 不能惹崔花伤心。
[嘉宾] 17名了，又进步一点点。
[主播] 我不能用别人来惩罚我自己啊。
[主播] 对吗？
[主播] juicy and sweet。
[主播] 还有一个呢，非常的 fresh。
[主播] fresh and cheap。
[主播] 很便宜的价格啊，各位朋友们。
[嘉宾] 还有人关注，我们马上105万粉丝了。
[主播] 105万的粉丝了。
[嘉宾] 这么帅气的主播，难道不要关注一下吗？
[主播] 这么帅气的主播，难道。
[主播] 攻我软肋啊。
[主播] 大家都知道我的曾用名叫中关村吴彦祖。
[主播] 昨天我叫彭于晏。
[主播] 今天我就暂时叫个这个中关村周杰伦吧。
[主播] 别骂。
[主播] 骂我就哭，我骂不过你我就哭。
[主播] 虽然我长得丑，但是我可以想得美。
[主播] 虽然我眼睛小，但是我的头大。
[主播] 所以你要善于发现自己的优点。
[主播] 'Nobody is flawless',没有人完美无瑕。
[主播] 'To err is human'。
[主播] 对吧，人非圣贤，孰能无过呀。
[嘉宾] 15名了。
[嘉宾] 加油。
[主播] 都卖成这个样子了，还能到15名了。
[主播] 所以有时候你不要不是自己做得好，是因为这么早大家都还没有睡醒，还没有开始卖货呢。
[嘉宾] 趁着大家没醒，我们加油。
[主播] 趁着大家没醒，能不能让我进一次前十名啊？
[主播] 可以吗？
[主播] 大家快右下角买一单，趁着其他主播没有醒，让我进次前十名。
[主播] 所有人右下角现在 'Everybody now' 现在右下角随便买一单。
[主播] 牛排，虾。
[嘉宾] 大家支持啊。
[主播] 或者水蜜桃都可以，右下角一号链接。
[主播] 请所有人拍一单，快。
[嘉宾] 一起助力，我们助力前十。
[主播] 所有人拍一单，拍一单，拍完了回复一拍好吗？
[主播] 帮我进一个前十名。
[主播] 我就想体验一下。
[主播] 人生重在体验。
[主播] 对吗？
[主播] 得不到的都是宿命。
[嘉宾] 14名了。
[主播] 已经14名了，快再买一些。
[主播] 朋友说莫名其妙的看了半天，这怎么能叫莫名其妙呢？
[主播] 对吧，你在挑战自己，挑战自己的生理极限。
[主播] 我就想知道我看着这样个硬的男主播，我能把自己憋多久？
[嘉宾] 13名了。
[主播] 13名了，你看。
[主播] 速度很快啊，朋友们。
[主播] 一共买了二单水蜜桃，就到了13名。
[主播] 所以你只要选选对了对手。
[主播] 人生每天都是进步。
[主播] 快乐就是这么来的。
[主播] 一定得比较，但一定得跟差的比。
[主播] 这样人生就快乐，豁然开朗，恍然大明白。
[主播] 都是人生智慧，赶紧记下，这要考的。
[主播] 英语不重要。
[嘉宾] 大家加了20单。
[主播] 人生也不重要。
[嘉宾] 老师，只有20单了。
[主播] 只有20单了。
[主播] 上。
[嘉宾] 好的。
[主播] 刚进入直播间的朋友，请大家点击左上方关注我们。
[主播] 我很难相信这么长时间11000人在直播间里早上听我在这胡扯淡。
[主播] 这是什么样的生活体验？
[嘉宾] 那咱们就再讲讲牛排。
[主播] 再讲讲牛排，好的。
[主播] 牛排是吧？
[主播] 牛排你先买啊。
[主播] 来，299,299这个价格很低了。
[主播] '12 pieces of steak, 12 pieces of steak'。
[主播] '12 pieces of steak',12片。
[主播] '24 bags of seasonings'。
[主播] 调料，调料叫 'seasonings'。
[主播] 唯一的配料表就是牛排，原切 'original cutting'。
[主播] 唯一的配料， 'the only'。
[主播] 写这个单词叫做 'ingredient'。
[主播] 快写了。
[主播] 配料表就是 'ingredient',快快快快，配料表 'ingredient'。
[嘉宾] 12名了。
[主播] 12名了，快买点，快买点。
[主播] 'The only ingredient is beef itself',唯一的配料就是牛肉啊。
[主播] 'The only ingredient is beef itself'。
[嘉宾] 啊？
[主播] 'No, I cannot say only'。
[主播] OK, OK, OK, OK, OK, I'm sorry。
[主播] 'So the word was not very proper', you know?
[主播] 因为抖音不让说啊。
[主播] 右下角一号链接大家赶紧去拍。
[主播] 现在已经12000人了。
[主播] 很难相信抖音是一个神奇的平台。
[主播] 大家在六月的清晨点进这个直播间来挑战自己的生理极限。
[主播] 看着主播兵马俑一样的脸型，感到了人生的无常和命运的不公。
[嘉宾] 12名了，哥。
[主播] 但是这个时候你发现跟我同样脸型的还有299,12片牛排送你的这一口锅。
[主播] 这口锅平常人卖都是多少钱？
[主播] 这锅人平常卖都是199,今天免费送给你。
[主播] 这个锅你得背。
[主播] 不要害怕背锅，我跟你说委屈受的多了，你就发现自己脾气越来越长。
[主播] 退一步海阔天空，凭啥我退，人一世风平浪静你咋不忍？
[主播] 赶紧拍右下角一号链接啊。
[主播] 欢迎说这个，我你要背锅。
[主播] 这个锅该背就得背。
[主播] 不要争。
[主播] 你知道我今天早上的朋友们都非常友好，而且。
[嘉宾] 清除了18单啊。
[主播] 清除了18单了。
[嘉宾] 一号链接。
[主播] 一号链接，很好。
[主播] 大家赶紧去拍啊，右下角一号链接，买点。
[主播] 买点再走。
[主播] 好吗？
[主播] 这个不说英语不买，OK。
[主播] 'I can speak in English all the time, but please remember to buy something'。
[主播] 'I am now introducing the steak', okay?
[主播] 'Three pieces of rib eye from Argentina, four pieces of sirloin from Australia'。
[主播] OK, 'and another five pieces from America'。
[主播] 一共 'all together 12 pieces of steak'。
[主播] 'And also you get a pan, a frying pan for free, this frying pan is for free'。
[主播] 'Can you ever imagine that?'
[嘉宾] 我们进10名了。
[主播] 'This is unbelievable'。
[嘉宾] 能不能冲进前五？
[主播] 女人，你的名字叫做贪婪。
[主播] 我进了前十名你很满意了。
[主播] 但是你还想让我进前五。
[嘉宾] 崔花想进前五。
[主播] 朋友们。
[主播] 崔花等我60年了。
[主播] 我们俩自由恋爱。
[主播] 崔花等我攒够了一头买牛的钱，就回乡下跟她结婚。
[主播] 关进粮食，生个孩子。
[主播] 面朝大海，春暖花开。
[主播] 崔花给了我黑色的眼睛。
[主播] 我却用它来中关村钢铁森林里办公。
[主播] 崔花呀。
[主播] 草在结它的种子。
[主播] 风在摇它的叶子。
[主播] 你我相隔千里静坐着，默不作声，这样就很美好。
[主播] 崔花，请你记住此刻的美好。
[主播] 牛排我已经给你买了。
[主播] 60岁的崔花跟70岁的董宇辉自由恋爱。
[嘉宾] 大家。
[嘉宾] 加了50单。
[主播] 今天加了50单。
[嘉宾] 一号链接只有50单了。
[主播] 只有50单了。
[主播] 自己去买，赶紧。
[主播] 能不能让我进次前十名？